in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right
yet to fail all the same
[Applause]
read it
run from it Dustin's still alive
[Music]
not on my watch [ __ ] happy new
year everyone this is gonna be my 2018
movie preview there's so many movies
coming that I couldn't do TV stuff in
this so this is just for big comic-book
movies or related stuff like Star Wars
is not technically a comic book
franchise but people think of it that
way so like I added the Star Wars Han
Solo movie to this if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything as you will see as we
go through the video there's gonna be so
much stuff that's gonna be really really
cool quick rundown there are 24 movies
total on this and I omitted a lot of the
stuff that's either unreal event or not
comic book or just look like it's gonna
be hot garbage and I'm probably not
gonna do video 4 so right off the bat
February in December are the busiest
months but the summer movie season as
per usual will be when the biggest
movies dropped so you'll see how this
breaks down starting us off Valentine's
Day weekend tip of the spear
Black Panther the untitled cloverfield
sequel that we still have not seen a
trailer for that's from JJ Abrams it
should be pretty cool but they quite
literally told us absolutely nothing
about it the tomb raider movie which
might wind up being hot garbage in
Pacific Rim 2 which fair warning might
also wind up being hot garbage because
Guillermo del Toro left the project and
they turned it into more of a
Transformers movie then the only real
big movie in March is ready player one I
know a lot of you are really hyped up
about that the only real big thing in
April is gonna be Fox's New Mutants
that's still part of the x-men universe
until we find out what Marvel is gonna
do with all those characters May is
obviously the beginning of the summer
movie season we have Infinity Ward just
blowing up everything that you know
about what a big movie can be is
surprisingly the Han Solo movie is still
on schedule for the end of that month
even though it sounds like Ron Howard
reshot most of that we should have a
trailer for that really soon too June is
like the beginning of sequel territory
we have Deadpool 2 then Incredibles 2
then Jurassic world to which fair
warning might also wind up being hot
garbage who knows but I'll do a video
for it either way then in July we have
ant-man in the
wasp Mission Impossible 6 which even if
your aren't a big Mission Impossible fan
henry cavill is playing the villain in
that where he had to wear a mustache
which is the origin of mustache gate for
justice league so i'd recommend even if
you're not a huge fan of movies that you
go see it just for the sick fascination
of seeing where that mustache came from
you know the other end of hot garbage
depending on who you talk to there's an
actual Teen Titans go movies in theaters
but if you've been avoiding that series
there's no reason to go see the movie
the only real big thing in August is
gonna be Shane Black's predator movie I
don't know if there's gonna be a cameo
from Schwarzenegger but they'll probably
be some Easter eggs for the classic film
so if you're a big predator fan this
actually seems like it'll be legit [ __ ]
October is when the Benham movie is
gonna drop we haven't seen any footage
from it yet that'll probably happen
pretty soon we've only seen the logo so
far oh you merely adopted the dark I was
born in it no surprise they're dropping
John Carpenter's Halloween reboot right
before Halloween then in November we
have Dark Phoenix who knows how that's
gonna turn out we haven't seen any
footage from it yet it could be hot
garbage it doesn't really matter because
Disney bought box and if the deal goes
through in a couple years they can just
reboot that universe so hopefully they
bring it but there's a fantastic beasts
equal and then wreck-it Ralph - they
also just released a teaser for wreck-it
Ralph - so I might do a video for that
next but December is also like the
busiest month of the year because there
are four movies so spider-man into the
spider verse
wait so how many of us are you
mortal engines which is the Peter
Jackson franchise based on the book
series and then closing the year down we
go Christmas we have the Aquaman movie
in the Transformers bumblebee movie
don't know a lot about what's going on
with bumblebee know a little bit more
about what's going on with Aquaman so we
should see some footage from that
relatively soon at last the firstborn of
beloved Queen Atlanta it's yours the
stuff I'm most excited about
obviously Infinity Ward can't wait to
see what that ends up looking like black
panther looks really solid Deadpool -
and I'm just weirdly fascinated with the
Han Solo movie because of all that
behind-the-scenes drama that went down
last year
hi well as we wrap up production I just
want to take this moment to thank an
incredibly talented cast and crew for
all their hard work and to the fans out
there I hope you've enjoyed the pictures
that I've been sharing pictures that
I've taken from the set of can we even
say the name of the movie I'll see you
next year
but most the movies on my list here I'm
really excited about there were only
couple like I mentioned that might wind
up being garbage I think most of them
will at least be good if not great but
if that sounds like a list that's a
little too long for you to handle like
hey I can't pay for 24 movies in a year
the really important ones are Black
Panther in February New Mutants in April
infinity war and Han Solo in May
Deadpool 2 in June ant-man in the wasp
in July venom in October Dark Phoenix in
November then spider-man and Aquaman in
December so obviously that doesn't
include any of the new TV shows like the
Deadpool animated series or the Titans
TV series in all the deal with the new
streaming services the people are
rolling out if you're worried about not
having money to see all this stuff
generally budget for the movies it's a
lot easier to find TV for free than it
is to find movies if there's anything
that you're really hyped up about that I
did not include in the video and you
want me to do videos for it just let me
know in the comments below but
a new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and just share the video
using the YouTube tools on the watch
page congratulations to the winner from
my last video earlier today jari fuller
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll just name a
new winner the next time I post new
marble you can click here for that brand
new Black Panther video and you can
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]